foreign
CDs to pen drives to hard disks the
error of these tools is now gone almost
everything is now present in cloud
storage whether it be an individual or
any organization everyone now relies on
cloud storage predictions show that over
200 zettabytes of data will be stored in
the cloud by 2025. for your information
one zettabyte is equal to a billion
terabytes now imagine the amount of data
present in the cloud storage this shows
the dependability of the modern world on
the cloud do you still feel that cloud
computing will ever go down in the
future the answer is a big no in fact
cloud computing will grow for as long as
the data is available on this planet the
cloud computing Market is supposed to
reach 1250 billion dollars by 2027
coming from 545 billion dollars in 2022
now imagine this Field's potential and
how much you learn if you successfully
bag a job in this booming it feed today
we'll let you know about a few of the
highest paid jobs in cloud computing so
hey everyone and welcome to Simply do in
this video we'll talk about the best
cloud computing bootcamp of 2023. by the
end of this video you will know which
boot camp you should choose to grab an
exciting and high paying package in 2023
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
interesting please subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you did also hit the Bell icon to
get notified whenever we drop a new
video so without any further delay let's
get started before we talk about the
best cloud computing bootcamp here is a
quick question for you guys which cloud
computing career in the current IIT
industry is the highest paid your
options are a cloud network engineer B
Cloud architect C Cloud security analyst
or D Cloud administrator
let us know your answer in the comment
section below and watch the video Until
the End to find out which are the jobs
with highest pay the salary of a working
professional is what makes a profession
worth choosing for anyone for cloud
computing the average salary of a cloud
architect is around 106 thousand dollars
there are two technologies which are
required AWS and Azure are the
Technologies one should Master to become
a cloud computing expert people usually
choose to get certified in any of them
but we at simply learned duly cares
about our viewers so we have the Caltech
coding bootcamp just for you to master
both Azure and AWS this in-depth cloud
computing online bootcamp course lets
you master fundamental principles and
develop the skills needed to become a
cloud expert you can become a complete
Cloud architect in just six months
whether you are a fresher looking to
make a career in the field of cloud
computing or any working professional
looking for a change in your career you
can opt for this cloud computing
bootcamp not just that but there are
many other attractive features of this
boot camp like 40 plus Hands-On projects
and integrated Labs will help you
understand the concepts much better
Capstone projects info domains make sure
that you have mastered this technology
completely a bootcamp certificate from
Caltech ctme is worth mentioning in your
resume
live virtual classes led by industry
experts Hands-On projects and integrated
Labs simply learns career service is
here to help you get noticed by the top
hiring companies
several other features are also there in
this boot camp in simple terms Caltech
cloud computing bootcamp helps you
become an expert in designing planning
and scaling Cloud implementations our
cloud computing course lets you master
the core skill sets required to develop
and deploy dynamically scalable and
reliable applications on Microsoft Azure
and Amazon web services
from cloud provider selection
application migration and performance
testing to database management
multi-cloud deployment and storage
Services we have covered every skill in
this program to help you become a
successful Cloud architect
so are you ready to work for companies
like Microsoft Google Oracle LinkedIn
and Accenture so please don't wait until
it's too late check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
we are here to guide support and Empower
you with the skills that keep you ahead
in the race everyone today knows about
cloud computing a simple and proper
definition of cloud computing is cloud
computing refers to the practice of
utilizing remote servers hosted on the
internet to store manage and process
data providing on demand access to wide
range of computing resources and
services
cloud computing is set to create 13.8
million jobs by the end of 2023. so
let's talk about the different job roles
present in cloud computing
Cloud network engineer
the job of a network or Cloud engineer
is to execute design and manage
day-to-day support and maintenance of
network and cloud services
they are also tasked with identifying
the best cloud providers and scaling
cloud services to address growing
business needs to accomplish these tasks
the candidate must have expertise in
networking and Cloud hardware and
software
a strong background in server and
network infrastructure interfering and
security along with analytical and
problem solving skills is required to
get hired for this position the
candidate must be familiar with leading
Cloud providers namely Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform and also have a working
knowledge of cloud-based systems
so in the United States a cloud network
engineer can draw an average salary of
000 per year
the next one is network and Cloud
architect
Cloud Architects are responsible for
planning designing and upgrading various
Network and Cloud projects basically
developing an organization's overall
Computing strategy they work closely
with the ID team and act as their number
one resource when it comes to
troubleshooting issues related to
network architecture and suggesting
system enhancement
for succeeding in this role candidates
must possess good experience in handling
Network and Cloud Technologies plus they
should excel at technical problem
solving while having strong
communication skills in the United
States the average salary of a cloud
system architect is 125
000 per year the next is cloud database
engineer
Cloud database engineer is a
professional responsible for Designing
implementing and managing databases that
are hosted and operated within cloud
computing environments with workloads
moving to the cloud and the growing
popularity of database as a service
database administrators are increasingly
working with data in the cloud
responsible for managing cloud-based
databases these professionals play an
important role in guiding businesses
into new technologies such as the
internet of things blockchain and
artificial intelligence all of which
cloud computing enables people in this
role work directly with Business Leaders
managers and customers to find out the
most appropriate ways to apply data to
solve business problems
a cloud database engineer in the United
States can earn an average salary of
hundred and six thousand dollars per
year
Cloud security analyst
Cloud security analysts take on the
critical role of ensuring the security
of cloud systems within an organization
and recommending specific measures that
can strengthen the company's overall
security especially with regard to Cloud
usage
they need to work Hands-On to identify
potential flaws and addresses security
needs when an organization is migrating
to public Cloud the ideal candidates for
these jobs must have a solid CAC
background and knowledge of the latest
security protocols authentication and
certification
good analytical and communication skill
are basic requirements while those
familiar with cloud services like Amazon
web services Microsoft Azure and
Rackspace have an added advantage
us-based Cloud security analysts command
an average salary of 94
796 dollars per year
so these are the four job rules in the
current cloud industry that are paid the
most the job role of a cloud architect
is the most fascinating and high in
demand so if you want to make a
high-paying career in the field of cloud
and want to work as a cloud architect
for big organizations like Google or
Microsoft then enroll now in the Caltech
cloud computing bootcamp and Kickstart
your journey to become a successful
Cloud architect check out the
description box to know more about the
boot camp and with that we have come to
the end of this best cloud computing
bootcamp video I hope you guys must have
got an idea about which boot camp is the
best for you and why you should choose
it if you still have any questions or
doubts let us know in the comment
section below and a team of experts will
help you at the oldest thank you so much
for being here today we'll see you next
time until then stay safe and keep
learning with simply loan staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you